are you looking for a reasonably priced
car for day-to-day driving and this here
might be just the ticket
bina guys feel kar testify no dicen over
says it costs just four euros over 100
kilometers that's cheaper than the bus
or train you see at me eco fuel
ultra-compact runs on compressed natural
gas so it's easy on the wallet and the
environment bit in terms of performance
the CNG me is right in between the two
gasoline versions it's not a speedster
but it offers all you need for a
comfortable ride it's more than
respectable for an environmental stand
out from the side the me looks pragmatic
and down to earth let the headlights
give the front of snappy look the sport
variant has fog lights in the bumper
front and rear have the typical see
outlook under the skin it shares the
same DNA as the Volkswagen up although
the interior isn't necessarily luxurious
the cockpit does feature an elegant
design it's well laid out and there's a
sat-nav to guide the way because it's an
eco fuel car it's a manual transmission
fine hope says it has a small 68
horsepower engine it's a robust car with
decent acceleration good for city
driving delivering a top speed of 130
kilometers per hour on the motorway the
me still needs gasoline to warm up the
engine but after that it boasts an
average consumption of just 2.9 kilos of
CNG per 100 kilometers fully tanked it
holds 11 kilos of cng with an economical
driving style that yields a range of
almost 380 kilometers and in Germany it
can be refilled at one of 900 filling
stations busy I note says if you're not
sure where the next filling station is
the sat-nav will tell you after fifty
thousand kilometers the extra two
thousand euros for the C&G engine will
have paid for itself and you'll get a
savings of about 1.5 tons of co2 in the
process these are succulent ants como
funcionan Co nd opposite refilling the
gas tank is perfectly safe the fueling
nozzles can vary a bit from station to
station but you can't actually press the
button to start refilling until the
fueling nozzle is securely in place in
Germany at least tax benefits make CNG
quite a bit cheaper than gasoline
in Zion old life line hope sums up to
see at me with see and she offers just
79 grams of co2 emissions per kilometer
hybrid cars need a lot of technology to
match that the engine is robust and
powerful enough for day-to-day driving
the car really shines in the city and a
full tank at less than 13 years in
Germany will surely bring a smile to
your face for that you need CNG his last
tip get the five-door variant which
offers easier access to the rear bench
hosting step defense really give
oriented and uncommon efficient alone
big femur of the exits bank